if you're watching the Microsoft press
conference yesterday you know that
sunset overdrive Xbox one is exclusive
is having a big showing here at e3 2014
joining me now on stage is Ted price
founder of insomniac games
Ted big III for you guys in sunset
overdrive it is it's been really
exciting for us to have people come by
play the game show off and for us to
show off what makes it different and
today we're showing it off we've got a
guy driving in the back is gonna be
jumping into some gameplay and we're
engine Eider our brand development
director is playing right now he's
actually looking out over one of the
spaces in the game this is a big open
world and you get missions throughout
what we are doing here is trying to make
our way to the roller coaster on the far
side to aid one of the friendly factions
in the game because there's an enemy
faction there are around this game you
they're your friends but what we're
demonstrating here is just that this is
not your traditional shooter you are
moving through the world with velocity
and aggression you are grinding bouncing
somersaulting vaulting throughout the
world and this really is important when
it comes to the combat in the game and
it seems like you know that grinding
it's you know you guys are doing a lot
to make it make it easy for folks to get
into get airborne get bouncing off stuff
get on these grinds but there's a reason
for it Brian's gonna probably
demonstrate here he's actually choosing
the one-handed dragon which is one of
our favorite weapons in the game this is
a weapon that shoots fire pits big
firecrackers and it lights nearby
enemies on fire so I see now one of the
one of the challenges that Ryan's gonna
face here is that he's on the ground and
when we're on the ground in this game
the enemies can be pretty brutal and
even though he's using the vinyl
launcher which is our record gun which
bounces off has records of bouncing
between enemies
these guys will destroy him but we make
it fun to die and so when you come back
and respawn boom there's more that
interesting fashions just in a rocket
but and you know if in some of the
trailers you guys have shown like
getting dropped off in a van just
chucked out of it or coming out of a
sarcophagus that's right I love the
playful attitude well fun trunks real is
this game and here's another example you
Ryan has just activated the Pandora's
box it is decided to throw out a whole
bunch of lawn gnomes who are fighting on
his behalf yes yes right now you'll
notice too that when Ryan spending a lot
of time grinding and that's because as
you do more and more complex moves in
the world you build up the style meter
which is on the top right-hand side of
the screen huh
the more you build it up the more amps
you trigger here's another one of our
traps is the flame trap in the game as
you start building up your style and
activating amps you get new abilities
and these are crafted abilities in the
game here's another example of one of
our environmental toys that was the test
of strength that Ryan is used to
electrify nearby enemies button looks
safe as he was bailing you probably saw
some tornados moving out from his melee
action you said dodge roll there's
another amp that's attached to the hero
Anson gentle though you craft them and
they can be attached to your hero or
your weapons which adds a lot of
strategy to combat because you can share
a ton of amps and go to some of the game
but you got to customize the amps you
want to coincide with your play style
that's correct
and I noticed there's a lot of like
those things are blowing up on this
carousel ride a little bit about you
know destructibility how things explode
and the way that you can sort of leave
your mark on the environment yeah the
environment is interactive so we give a
players a lot of opportunity to
experiment and have fun with all the
little like Easter eggs that we put
around the world and given that this is
a big open world there are a ton of
things to discover for the players now
throughout the game you're going on
missions and quests and following a
pretty deep storyline
and this your player is helping these
friendly factions in the game going on
for a second here is a hooker just one
of her larger and enemies in the game
he's a former construction worker who
mutated around this big digger arm he
really did and he's and it just is like
the way the sinews and muscles are sort
of around the metal and it's exposed
like there's so much environmental
there's an attention to detail here it's
really just popping off the screen well
we're having fun with this I mean this
is us at insomniac letting loose and
really adhering to that mantra that fun
trumped realism and at the same time
this is a game that is will challenge
players because these enemies are tough
you know a lot of them and when it comes
to the bigger enemies they're not your
standard big enemies either this time
particular is agile he will climb
buildings after you he will charge you
he will do a lot of damage but he's also
susceptible to fire weapon and so what
ryan been on fire for like two minutes
right right it's using a flaming
compensator which is our shotgun he just
killed him there by firing out a couple
of TN teddies which are exploding teddy
bears that you can launched from a
single turn now Ryan's gonna make his
way over to the roller coaster by
bouncing and grinding through another
fairly frenetic section of the amusement
park here being on the ground can mean
death so he's getting up onto the wires
and grinding by so that's one of my
questions is you know if how are you
guys encouraging players who you know
from falling into that sort of familiar
third-person shooter trap up I stay on
the ground I walk around I shoot enemies
one of the ways we do it is by having
players are in style
I mentioned the style meter and that's
really important when it comes to combat
because as you're crafting exams in the
game the way to activate them is to
build your style meter and you can
actually max it out and when that
happens you're triggering these epic
amps which just do ridiculous amounts of
destruction around you but in a way
that's very over-the-top and very sunset
overdrive stylized
so what I'm doing right now is he's
actually on the
toaster which has been taken over by
scabs these this other faction in the
game so he's trying to take out the
towers that surround the central tower
where the scab King is hiding out and
blow up some of these roller coaster
cars that have scabs riding in them
along the way the od'd who these
overcharge delirium drinkers have taken
over that they've been fighting against
the scabs and so they're climbing up all
over the roller coaster - you got a
couple different factions at war that we
do fighting each other as well but an
important aspect of this particular
element are part of the game is that
every one of our missions has unique you
can't mechanics and story-driven beams
behind them so we want to keep things
very fix it up mix up four players and
we take that sort of handcrafted
approach that we have in previous games
like the Ratchet and Clank series to
make sure that no players are always
wondering what's gonna happen during the
next mission absolutely and I am
honestly wondering what gun is gonna
come up next I don't know folks who are
fans of GameSpot hopefully know the gun
show it's a show I started just sort of
looking at Arsenal's and games and how
to use them and how cool they are and
the game that inspired it was resistance
- right and you guys so I am super
thrilled anytime they whip out a new
weapon and just to see what it does you
will get a lot of specials in this game
so what we can show now if we have some
time is male spot Kaos Squad is our
multiplayer element of the game it's a
big multiplayer experience where you and
a friends are earning loot you are
working together to save sunset City the
way you do this is you play through the
open world just like an Oran campaign
but with friends and along the way you
are going on these missions that involve
combat traversal scavenger hunts
competitions and as you succeed in every
mission you get a choice of in terms of
which mission you will go on next Oh
interesting system if you're really
being kind of choosing your way through
yeah you're voting on a series a lot of
brand emissions that come up and that
vote is actually important because at
the very end of your mission sequence
you go to what we call night defense
this is a over-the-top explosive round
where you and your aprons are defending
bats of overcharge from marauding
and at the very end if you succeed then
you win rewards new weapons new vanity
new amp recipes new cash overcharge that
you can actually take back into the
single-player campaign okay but it's a
big experience and there's a lot of
variety within it here at e3 we are
showing just the night defense which is
again this nighttime over-the-top
everyone descending on this one area or
is it you know how big is this area that
you're sort of I guess here it's
centered around those vets the oka
rabbits so you can venture out away from
the bats if you want to but then it
starts some things start to get
difficult you need to work together to
keep the over od'd out of the base and
before this I'm just imagining you know
we saw yesterday during the press
conference the sort of four player
Assassin's Creed running in a pack and
really you know cutting their way
through I'm trying to picture that with
eight sunset overdrive players running
their way through the city and it just
seems like mayhem it's we know what
because their players have such agility
because you can grind and balance
involved it's actually really fun to run
with seven other people and watch them
as they are screaming down the streets
on on power lines or bouncing from car
to car and there's a lot of some races
in the game as well so you're racing
through the city with your friends very
cool one thing that I what we are asked
a lot is this looks like an explosive
game there's so much going on I think
the more exclusive and over the top has
been said not to hundred percent more in
this demo than in many others so people
asked where's the strategy where's the
depth in the game and we actually we
have a lot of enemy variety we have a
lot of opportunity to change up combat
for players using a very widely diverse
array of weapons and amps on top of that
which is the crafting system door and
add the traversal and it's a very
different type of shooter in fact this
is us changing the rules when it comes
to shooters and offering shooter fans
something different in terms of what
shooter fans love a deviation from
perhaps what we've been playing for the
last decade yeah I'll say yeah and it's
you know you guys obviously taking a
pretty tongue-in-cheek jab at that
during the press conference yesterday
and the soldier guy parked behind his
crate you know what
been doing for the last 10 years we've
been cowering behind cover right and we
pop up and we shoot yeah I mean we've
made shooters right we're a cover based
at insomniac and our goal was to change
things up to throw the old rules out the
window and try something different and
that goes for the tone as well in this
game know this we we poke fun at
ourselves we poke fun at court cultural
conventions yeah we break the fourth
wall all the time the character himself
is very self-aware but at the same time
it's not just it's not just the
character it's you in the game we allow
players to customize their characters
however they want from the very
beginning where there's gender ethnicity
body style vanity hair style and you can
change it up at any time in the game as
well all right so you I think you've
been commit showing off mainly a male
character in sort of the demos but
albeit with all sorts of crazy
hairstyles but there's a lot more range
there in terms of what you can do to
customize absolutely and we're showing
off that today at Kay and chaos squad as
well at night defense we have a wide
variety of characters that we our
designers just decided to create for e3
so players will be able to choose from a
very broad palette excellent choices
very cool Ted well sunset overdrive you
know seeing it in action in here and you
talk about I feel like I'm getting a
better sense for what the game is all
about any chance of like a demo ahead of
the of the games released so the players
can really get kind of a feel for this
quite divergent game style you guys are
trying on well right now all I can talk
about is the demo we have here okay and
there's a great chance for people to get
their hands on it get familiar with the
again different way of traversing
through the world and play with their
friends really experience some of the
weapons and some of the depth that we
have in the game fantastic said thank
you so much for coming on showing off
sunset overdrive folks we are gonna go
check in with the GameSpot news